and watching the post Takens at me from
one of its own employees over this
headline with record coveted cases China
scrambles to plug in immunity Gap
coronavirus Outbreak on the verge of
being China's biggest of the pandemic is
supposed a critical flaw in beijing's
zero covid strategy a vast population
without natural immunity but not to be
outdone controversial reporter Taylor
Lorenz responding with this quote there
is no lasting natural immunity to covet
you can get coveted over and over and
over again because there are so many
endlessly evolving strains and
antibodies weighing also choosing not to
kill off millions of vulnerable people
as the U.S is doing isn't a critical
flaw Fox News contributor Joe joins us
now Joe is her prospective Pro
authoritarian lockdown an anti-vaccine
is that what she's trying to say here
but it appears that's the case and
instead of Carly Taylor Lorenz just
going to her editors privately and
saying hey I have a problem with this
piece she's got to put on a public show
to try them to embarrass her employer I
mean it's utterly astonishing that this
activist who plays a reporter on TV and
in print is still employed by the
newspaper I mean think about what she's
advocating here for a second what she
supports a communist government that
locked people in apartment buildings in
one city in an effort to contain covid
and when a fire broke out 10 people died
because firefighters couldn't get to
them because the doors were welded shut
there's one Chinese City that that's
called an isolation that has an
isolation camp with 90 000 isolation
pods 90 000 and Taylor Lorenz is this
reporter supports all this she wants the
U.S to impose similar lockdowns here
apparently I mean remember this is the
same reporter who claims you got PTSD
from Mean Tweets thankfully the Chinese
people have had enough they're taking to
the streets they're risking their own
lives in protest testing these
government lockdowns and I think what we
learned here in the U.S is that covet
can't be contained and lockdowns are not
the answer but the Washington Post has
its most prominent face at least on
social media saying she supports these
measures in China I mean Jeff Bezos must
be so proud at this point Todd she's not
alone though Joe it's not like Taylor
Lorenz is the only person who has these
views there are so many on the left who
seem like they want to live in their
parents basements forever they never
want to go outside they want to live in
a Perpetual state of coveted lockdowns
in the off chance that they get this
thing will people on the far left Taylor
Lorenz included ever be happy unless we
are all locked in our homes forever
apparently not thankfully a good
majority of Americans say no we we want
to we understand that covet is here we
have to learn to deal with it in terms
of Therapeutics if we do get it how to
handle getting it but to stay indoors I
mean the way you get coveted at least in
my household because it's happened three
times is is when one person all it takes
is one person brings it home and then
everybody gets it while they're in their
homes right uh so you got to get out you
got to be free and most importantly that
that's the best thing for businesses and
for mental health uh for that matter but
then we heard Dr fauci just over the
weekend Todd talking about how he
doesn't he's not quite sure after the
holidays whether schools should be
locked down again or not if there's a
rise in covet cases enough the data in
science says that's not the way you go
about this absolutely and then when it
comes to what's really going on in in
China Joe it's unbelievable you have uh
people in cities across the country
fighting back against an authoritarian
regime President Biden so far I don't
believe has said anything about this do
you expect him to to and how important
would his messaging be here
well he was in Nantucket over the
weekend you know of course he couldn't
be bothered to talk about this what's
going on in China again where people are
dying as a result of being isolated
during these lockdowns but yeah the
president United States should be
standing up like the 45th president
would have by now to say that this is
wrong uh and and also by the way ask for
answers as to where covet began was it
in that lad in Wuhan that studies
coronaviruses seems pretty logical but
when the president had a chance
President Biden that is he did not not
challenge uh jizen paying in terms of
anything regarding covet and you have to
ask why is that why is this President So
Soft on this particular country where
his son made so much money possibly
illegally through influence peddling I
guess we're going to find out January
3rd when the new Congress takes takes
office and hearings begin on that front
Carly will definitely be a very New Year
yes Joe thank you thanks Joe yes we
appreciate it I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian
kill me and I'm Ainsley Earhart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis